well writer Mandy LEM Catron's landmark
article for The New York Times series
modern love is one of the newspapers
most read essays the articled
fall in love with anyone do this is
about her recreation of an intimacy
experience with an acquaintance she
asked him thirty-six personal questions
like when did you last cry in front of
another person then she stared into his
eyes for four minutes the essay was
widely shared that acquaintance actually
became her boyfriend mandolin Catrin has
published her first book it's filled
with personal essays how to fall in love
with anyone takes a candid look at her
own life she explores the psychology of
relationships and the myths we all
create about romance and she argues that
love stories limit our idea of what's
possible in love the book is published
by Simon & Schuster which is it which is
a division of CBS and mandolin Catrin
joins us at the table good morning to
you morning good morning to you brave
woman cut it all out there your
personalized stories I know we'll find
out at the end of this interview if you
guys are still together with okay sounds
good I love that you open about talking
about your parents own divorce who told
you and your sister when you were 26
years old that we're getting a divorce
and now that sort of shake shake to you
a little bit because it showed you that
there are no guarantees in love yeah I
mean I think for most of my life I just
thought if you're a good person yeah you
don't do anything to betray your spouse
in any way that that's really all you
need to do to have a long stable
marriage and when my parents split up I
was shocked and I kind of thought wow
maybe a lot of what I think about love
is actually wrong yeah because you said
most of us think love marriage baby
carriage yeah yeah there's a script I do
baby care yes and if that will make you
have a happy life and what should we be
thinking now well I what I've learned
through the book which is just I've read
a ton of love stories and thought about
the role of love stories in our culture
and basically I think the fact is most
stories really narrow the way we can
think about love and suggest that
there's like one right way to love and
that will make you happy I mean the
reality is that there are lots of ways
that love can be a part of our lives I
was so struck actually by the last law
in your your actual original article
where it says that you say here falling
in love is not the same as staying in
love like falling in love is the easy
part is what you say yeah well because I
think so many of our stories are really
about like how two people get together
but ultimately like we don't talk that
much about what it means to stay in a
relationship and what that looks like
and how that works and we would really
benefit from having more stories about
stuff like that
and a lot of it comes from the movies
that you talk about whether it's you
mentioned Notting Hill you mentioned
dirty dancing and that's the same sort
of story those movies I believed but
they fell the falling in love part of
they not the staying in love part of it
yeah yeah I think so I mean and so the
staying in love I mean part of that
comes from and sustaining the
relationship comes from part of it the
questions that you that they came up in
the article and this is a 20 year old
study that you sort of put in the
zeitgeist right yeah by when you when
this essay came out what why is it
important for folks to talk about these
questions the thing about the questions
is it's it's not like they're
necessarily a shortcut to creating
romantic love but they do sort of
statistically-significant lots of
studies have shown this that they do
create intimacy and closeness really
quickly and it's a process that I think
normally can take weeks or maybe even
months and it accelerates it into like
you know a couple of hours do that man
yet you're at an at a bar I'll take the
Merlot and how do you feel about your
relationship with your mother a little
awkward yeah no I think but if you don't
get along with his mama
Rina that's a big old red flag question
number twenty waving a red flag like
what please go ahead I think you have to
be really transparent about it like I
think you have to say I read about this
study it sounds interesting like would
you like to try it I know a couple of
people wouldn't do that I did you did
yeah but I didn't know I was gonna do it
it sort of came out it sort of came up
in conversation let's go to the title
about how to fall in love with anyone
remember when I loved the title and I
want to know what exactly do you mean by
that
how do you do that well I don't think
it's I don't think you can fall in love
with just like random person on the
street mhm but I do think the reality
about love is we often think about it is
this thing that happens to us and and
we're just sort of passively accepting
whatever love throws our way but the
truth is we have a lot more agency than
that and that we can really choose to
invest ourselves in another person and
that might need to Lowe and you say how
you meet somebody also determines the
validity of the relationship with your
friends and family if you feel supported
by friends and family with how you meet
somebody yeah better their chances what
do you mean by that well there's lots of
research that shows that how do you meet
someone influences how much support you
get from the people around you like if I
met like if you meet someone at a bar
versus meeting someone at like a
community center or a church or
something like that
and there's also research that shows the
more your friends and family approve of
your partner the longer your
relationship is likely to last Wow
I get that and when you fall out of love
people want an explanation they want to
know it's not enough to know that we
just it just didn't work out they want
to know exactly what happened yeah one
thing I think is really interesting
about romantic love is that we're really
okay with like not knowing much about
how how like why two people got together
or how they stay together we want this
process to be super mysterious but when
someone breaks up we want all the
details and we want to know why and one
of the things that I discovered once I
started thinking about that and my
parents divorced and my own long-term
relationship ending was that actually we
oversimplifies yeah like it's really
complicated short-term relationships can
be important and okay - yeah that was an
interesting point you may yeah I always
have to leave - love marriage and baby
hahaha that's a whole separate subject
talk about one-night stands I'm talking
about I'm not talking about that ya know
anywhere from one to you just want
somebody whispered especi though here
every now and then is that point thing
is that it's a whole different subject
call explore not tomorrow with Mandy but
future articles I'm sure her man guy you
took the test with what's going on we're
still together you still together do you
think you're together because of the
test or do you think it opened up other
thing I think doing the questions just
sort of open it helped me trust him in a
way that I didn't trust other people I
had dated and I think that was a great
starting point yeah and the questions by
the way are in the book yeah that you
did that page 223 the questions again
questions mandolin Catrin thank you so
much thank you guys for having me how to
fall in love with anyone who's on sale
now